what is going on there citizens of the reject
Nation we apparently got ourselves a final
trailer for The Super Mario Brothers movie
join with me today John how are you it's me
I'm excited I'm the first person to join
us with a trailer they were just about to
shoot a movie reaction but this dropped and we
haven't moved reaction that just went up today
Jennifer's Body they have Puss in Boots it's
rocks dryer yeah a lot of people just saying
your name there the only response is it's a me
and you stole it to me but it's also a me it's
me a Roxy yeah there you go see it works guys
follow Roxy on the World Girls YouTube channel
you could also follow her on her social
media it's the only thing that keeps her
coming back in other words validation ladies
and gentlemen leave a like comment below who
your favorite Mario character is quickly who
is it oh Luigi Peach Chris Pratt let's go
where am I oh fresh meat for the grind yes
Luigi's Mansion Vibes he is cute but he is
It's gotta be a way out of
here there's no escape the
only hope is the sweet really fun
day oh you've got to be kidding me
my Army Koopas Goombas whatever those things are
destroy the Mushroom Kingdom
Bowser is coming I'm not afraid I'll do
anything for my brother we're going to save him
Epic
the run for it this is fun
I'm so excited for this Mad Max Rainbow Road sick
sick wow
[Music]
pretty sure I've done that
move yes throw it throw it
the very Mario Kart heavy trailer yeah suck
at throwing those damn green shells I suck at
throwing them third time to charm just now so yeah
you'll get there one day that really capitalized
on the epicness the I saw like an Avengers level
movie so so bombastic with action sequences and
Mario and Donkey Kong teaming up I'll throw it to
you Roxy what'd you think I thought that that was
of the trailer so far the most that looked like I
was watching my brother play the game like it just
looks like the video game in a cool way like it
actually showed that they're going to be pulling
a lot from the game and also I love Peach and this
had the most peach in it so go Peach it looks like
Peach is going to be whooping ass Peach is woke
right Roxy Peach is dope that's what matters the
most people are gonna walk away from this going
this is an sjw right Rock come on because she has
no political opinions at all oh my God why are you
pushing your agendas here in this video Ryan what
did you think Peach I can't help it we've got big
eyes we look identical to each other I've got to
push my agenda I don't know which one to shoot
I just setting you up no yeah I thought this I
think that's a really good call this one feels
the most like you're watching moments ripped out
of the games and you've got your Peach action for
me last trailer they've referenced you know Luigi
Mansion here they're in a big spooky situation
they keep teasing me with these Luigi's Mansion
Vibes and so I'm just hoping this does well
enough to get that movie greenlit but yeah uh
I love the just sheer scope of like we're throwing
all of Bowser's forces Goombas Koopas and whatever
you spiky Turtles are called and uh yeah like
the combination of that that like big Epic War
quality but with all the candy colors and fun of
the Mushroom Kingdom and all that stuff this looks
like a blast and it's funny to me that Chris Pratt
is still like the least featured vocal character
I still hide his voice quite a bit do you think
on purpose because it's not that good or why yeah
I I'm under the impr I mean I'm still waiting to
find out you know I will wait to judge because but
I do think that there's a lack of it's just Rings
like a lack of confidence to me because of the
fact that it is it's Mario it's called the Super
Mario Brothers movie he's smart he's the title
lead character they should be showing a little
bit more of his voice but the little bits I've
heard haven't been um like upsetting to me in any
regard uh but I think Charlie Day's voices Luigi
is perfect I think he's absolutely nailing it and
what's cool about this is that there's such a big
variation of Mario games you know you got Super
Smash Brothers you got Mario Kart you got Paper
Mario got Super Mario Odyssey you got Mario Party
Mario Party Luigi's man and it feels like they
have creep managed to create a movie in a world
right it's just a trailer it should be a great
trailer it does feel like they managed to create
a movie in a world where all of it's going to be
able to mesh together in a great way with and even
capitalizing on the Mario Kart with the with the
Rainbow Room side of things feels like a little
psychedelic to me yeah which is something I wasn't
expecting to to say out of this film um but I'm
also excited for like because they seasoned the
trailer and Donkey Kong and Mario fight and now
they're showing and then teamed up together I does
feel like we are building to some giant Nintendo
Cinematic Universe of sorts needless to say who do
you think you're going to like most after seeing
the movie uh I feel like I feel I honestly all
jokes aside I feel like Peach will probably be a
scene and Luigi I feel like it's gonna be Peach
and Luigi thank you so much I have a lot invested
in her thank you as well because I have a lot
of Investments yeah I'm just going to say I just
wanted to keep you guys happy I'm just gonna say
toad to be a contrarian and I love Keegan Michael
Key he is great they do get some incredible actors
to be the voices yeah it's weird how like with
that with so much Chris Pratt controversy like
pretty much every other casting choices like
that's a great call yeah really well done I love
the part because as much as I love the Mario games
I do forget the names of so many of the creatures
and characters from time to time so when Bowser
is listening off like Koopas Koopas whatever you
guys are like that is so relatable I think for a
lot of audience members because there are a lot
of these reoccurring creatures that appear in the
games and I have no idea what they're called to
this day even though they appear in like multiple
video games somebody at home is screaming at the
TV right now this is what they're called leave
a comment yeah I know they're called rollers
usually something pretty simple it's a blockhead
or something of that regarding except for Jack
Black yeah I love Jack Black and he does have
a really unique voice I've heard actually
some people not stoked about him he's the other
casting that I've heard people not that excited
about oh really I don't feel that way I'm I'm
really into Jack Black I feel like he's doing
a really everything we're hearing so far it
feels like he's the one who probably has the
perfect tone yeah out of everyone here and I
feel like people going into this were like I
Don't Know Jack Black because he's liable to
just be Jack Black and and for someone like me
that's appealing but here yeah I'm thrilled that
he seems to be throwing himself into the role and
they seem to have done uh maybe a little pitch
correcting two so it's a combination yeah him
doing the voice and then them editing it and so
yeah I think he's actually like the perfect guy
and he's a guy who like you could imagine acting
out all the posters yeah yeah absolutely and I
think that helps with something like this do you
guys feel like you have an understanding of what
the story is gonna be yeah it's really simple
there's this thing called the Mushroom Kingdom
it's way down here Bowser is creating all kinds of
tyranny Overlord warlord crap and then Mario gets
plunged into the Mushroom Kingdom and then he's
going to help save the day by working with the
oppressed it's kind of like Ant-Man and the WASP
quantumania plot line but um you know [Laughter]
yeah I love it I love it guys what did you think
about this trailer leave your thoughts down below
thank you Roxy for joining us looking forward
to you guys shooting the Ip Man reaction and
um I'm I'm Christian harloff this is Brett shirt
oh let's send this to the picture
Garth McMurray we have a patron of the day shout
out to do and then Roxy recognized your name right
away and what was your response to that I love
Garth he's the best he's amazing so thanks Garth
yeah for sure word Garth what's your favorite
thing about girth yeah make it personal and real
and relatable I know a lot about Garth actually
we've been with each other for a long time
um serious relief that he's an East Coast
dude that he knows a lot about comic books
that he's always very generous and supportive
uh he's got like a very challenging life and
backstory and he always tries to stay positive
and helpful to other people he's a good dude
dude Fred said you have for failure
and you are knocked that out of the
cars don't come at me with Garth trivia
well we just learned something about
you Garth well thanks for supporting
the reject Nation buddy see you guys soon [Music]